okay well uh take a moment here because
congratulations
and felicitations are in order today is
Matthew B gorley's birthday I know B is
now your middle name nor is today my
birthday I thought you said today's your
birthday I just no someone said this
episode is coming out on the 22nd my
birthday is the 23rd oh what the hell
man what right before we started didn't
you say this is coming out you asked me
when this is coming out and I said on
the 22nd then you go that's my birthday
week oh come on but that's what Conan's
birthday was on the 18th and we recorded
it on for the 17th so it's like the same
thing it's not like we can't talk about
it stop the whole momentum and the magic
to point out a small accounting error it
is more or less your birthday but now I
started off with this feeling of
generosity and everything and and now I
don't have it anymore
it's coming out the 22nd my birthday is
the 23rd all right well who's gonna
announce that to America on the 23rd you
going on The Price is Right what are you
doing that's exactly what I'm doing I'm
going on the prices right for my
birthday okay have you been have you
been on The Price is Right no but I have
been on more game shows than I'm of care
to admit is that true yeah when those
people that just went from game show to
game show when I was younger yeah when I
was younger yeah well I'm turning 50. I
mean yes this is your 50th birthday
tomorrow can we just say it's today sure
also people don't listen to podcasts
necessarily are you telling me how
podcasts well maybe as someone should
wow they don't necessarily listen the
day that they're put on air that's well
you lost it you lost it's okay you tried
no no they don't you know what I mean
yes drops but then someone might be
checking it out tomorrow and guess what
if it's the 23rd then happy birthday
Matt gorley and it's the big 5-0 eh yeah
that nothing yeah that ain't nothing I
don't know what are you talking about I
don't know I feel it you know 50 is I
mean with all the advanced is in science
and everything 50 is the new 49. 48. you
know
you can't worry about it I know that
you're first of all you're a very
youthful chap well you come across as
very young you you were getting kind of
upset when we'd mentioned your 60th
birthday yeah so you tell them because
and I'm upset now that you brought it up
again I'm trying to get it out on
Wikipedia that I'm 51 or 49. okay I'm
also trying to get some other stuff out
there too that I was in porno
porno yeah no people who are in who do
porn don't say I'm in porno this was a
long time ago when people said in porno
no I think porno was in you no it was
1981. oh it's a good porno time yeah I
was gonna say that's my favorite yeah
and back then we called it in porno did
you yeah sexy yeah someone would say hey
you what's your score and I'd say I'm in
porno that's the game
that's how people talk about anyway what
were some of your movies oh you don't
want to know I do want to know okay look
out unzip
that doesn't feel like look out because
Here Comes something sexually formidable
it feels like look out you're in danger
look out unzip was one of my
best-selling movies yeah for most of us
learning a second language in high
school or college wasn't exactly a high
point in our academic careers I uh
learned Spanish just many times over
yeah it didn't really stick no well
you're very Irish
okay that doesn't have anything to do
with and it's not like you went home to
anyone who spoke Spanish you just need
to practice it that's father my father's
from Spain oh I know
he's Theodore anyway now thanks to Babel
the language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn
the new language babble's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go with Babel you
can choose from 14 different languages
including
Spanish French Italian German there are
so many ways to learn with Babel in
addition to lessons you can access
podcasts games video stories and even
live classes plus it comes with a 20-day
money-back guarantee you know when I go
to another country I like to have some
facility with the language because it
shows that you're trying yeah it's like
a very uh courteous thing to do but it
could be tedious if it's like boring how
to learn it but this is fun I've tried
Babel you've tried that and it is really
fun they they do teach you things that
you'll use when you go to another
country and and it's stuff that sticks
right now get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
teamcoco that's babble.com teamcoco for
up to 55 off your subscription that's a
big chunk off your welcome World Babble
language for life so yeah I'm trying to
get that on the internet what was the
plot what's that what was the plot oh
there's this guy and he goes to get his
zipper fixed he wears these really tight
corduroy pants and this guy's packing
let me tell you is there any sex in it
at all I wouldn't call it sex what would
you call it but there is an extended
segment where the just the penis just
keeps coming out and out and out oh come
on like it's like a magician would pull
scarves out of their mouth well that's
it there's a scene where a magic he does
he's wandering the Earth trying to find
you know a way to make a living and then
he teams up with a magician at one point
and the guy is pulling out you know and
pulling and pulling and pulling and it
just keeps going and it's called look
out unzip
well look for
depends on which country it's released
I've seen ones that were you know I saw
a copy that was being sold in the Canary
Islands
okay but it depends on where you get it
but all of this all of this is my way of
saying happy 50th birthday
and you know what you should feel
grateful you have a beautiful wife yes
you have uh lovely daughters and a
gorgeous home I mean and you get to work
with Sona and Conan and that's that's a
pretty rare yeah I get to work with
Sonos
three together that might get worse
I'm gonna go sit on that two-legged
stool and see how that goes is that
another one of your in pornos yep well
that was that was one legged stool
that's the other one I made which didn't
do as well people were disappointed in
the ending
upside where I'm just sold as a stool
and then I'm just just a long sequence
of me erect this is and people are
having having coffee using my back as a
table birth in a minute I'm at a French
cafe and they're on really tall stools
because that's really packing yeah
yeah this is all true oh my God you know
maybe this is a great birthday present
for you it's not yes you can gather the
wife and daughter nope around the radio
that plays podcasts no and you can
listen to this wonderful memory I'm
gonna Salvage this by drinking out of
Javier bardem's cold coffee cup
oh there you go
now that's a birthday I can save her yes
very nice well happy birthday seriously
happy birthday girl thanks you guys
thanks we all did would it kill you to
lean into the mic and say happy birthday
happy well he told me it was the 22nd I
know but so what we let that go are you
still nursing that happy birthday it
seems like it seems like there are
qualifications to that yeah I don't
accept your happy birthday all right
well as long as we entered in bitterness
let's get out of here